als das seine kurz auf den boden jaja so
sperma oder ich nehme jetzt einfach nur
einzelne zombies altach dass eine
einzelne zombies der stadt noch ein
zombie auf an der sich als 3 kg gleich
tod glaube ich einfach mal weiter zu
kämpfen hätten auch noch welche ich geh
jetzt mal die andere richtung macht dass
es auf einmal richtig geil gemacht er
auch sagen
vier herzen eine weile her doch wir
können im nahkampf gehen und irland gilt
aber als nicht in welche richtung wir
gehen müssen wir jetzt ohne ball neue
zombies relativ scheiße ja ja ich weiß
ich bin ja in die andere richtung
hier sind überall so einzelne zombie
party explodiert auch zwischendurch
einfach mal zudem wurden als du das
einstürzen wie beim erdbeben hatte der
gast auf dem boden hocken wir den töten
verbrennt die anderen sachen
ich brenne auch nicht irgendwelche fall
der nähe ich habe wirklich keine pfeile
ist es relativ doof ich habe auch keine
pfeile verstehe nicht wo man überall
rüstung wieder bekommt und warum man
auch nie schaden nimmt und dann trotzdem
immer rüstung bekommt jetzt kommt wieder
überall zombies
ich versuche die von der seite weg zu
klatschen die beiden gelben die renten
diesen von psycho rennen so stark auf
dich zu und so weiß nicht was ist mein
tunnel gehen ob da noch etwas ist ich
glaube das ist einfach und ohne lehrer
ist nichts rein haben auf jeden fall
slaughter material hier geht doch noch
den weg weiter okay das erstmals gebäude
bringen
hier ist noch ein diamant amish für dich
hab ich eigentlich damit
immer dass das kind kennt was sind das
trink ich glaube schon mal den weg am
besten täglich vor den zombies ein
bisschen erklärt weglaufen
so eine waffe die habe ich noch gar
nicht benutzt und dies habe ich besser
als change worte benutzt auch die ganze
zeit hier kommt nicht so können wir
jetzt angehen
das sind solche garagen hatte die chat
generated was wissen
wir müssen jetzt durch finden was
gefunden
ich freue mich auf langes neues geht
sicher nicht ist schon ein knopf
hatte ich schon mal da ist kein knopf
hier ist aber dass pater b ich drücke
aufs startknopf
hier steht nah dran
er drückt die ganze zeit ich auch
kadlec tragen da sind wenn wir aus den
windsors klett okay noch mal probieren
und hier sind richtig
so war ok alle sind tot
die meisten vorkommen ich weiß nicht wo
ich bin
deswegen warte ich ganz kurz
irgendwie passiert nichts
du hast guckt man chatter steht hugo
fixed hat keiner gesagt
das heißt wir haben es wieder da hinten
hin laufen im tunnel sonics offen hier
kann man auch nicht gelangen
ja das einfach mal nach hinten schauen
ich bin schnell 48 wenn ich gleich
irgendwas verzaubern könnten es war so
geil dass eine tür offen geht wo bist du
einfach nur zombies kaputt schlagen
mitgenommen das richtig gemein doch
selber schuhe
der scanner kirche mit 4g scan klappt
noch schuhe kaufen
juli hier ist nix hier könnte man mal
reingucken ach da sind wieder so ganz
viele zombies scheiße schreibe hilf mir
ist kein diamant hose na toll noch nicht
angst aus diamanten nano
wir wollen jetzt ich muss mich wohl hier
wieder neu ausrüsten
denn neuen trinken und sich viele feinde
habe ich habe gar keine tränke dort sind
amazon keystone die verbrennen wenn sie
raus wollen hier geht's rein hier geht
sein dass es so eine abmahnung ab jetzt
die fabrikarbeit hierher kam hat er
längst lingens längst nicht hinter dir
hinter der hinter dir hinterher
ich würde sagen pfeiler und lange
entfernung einfach drauf schießen jedoch
nicht in der kampf nein
was soll ich hab genug weile
kanada mit nach köln das hat einfach
gemerkt
komisch maps folge da ich brenne darauf
endlich prozent liegt sony 3d laufen
nicht immer so flüssig schießt einfach
nur auf entfernungen diese leute ab die
am besten nicht im freien sondern kümmer
dich mal um den gast geht ja schlecht
immer leute um mich herum
wir sind jetzt den gast auf derbe weiter
entfernung zu treffen
getroffen ja ich weiß nich t shirt und
allein diese teile da oben sind auch
geil diese kanister da richtig krasse
müssen wir hin
ich bin weggelaufen sind die wieder
david fitz wo bist du
ach ja da sind zombies okay ist es mir
egal
service geht sind leute die leute hier
sind wir noch mehr hallo ja dass einer
jetzt erst mal ein steak einfach hier
unten fünf weg sind krass wieder drin
glaube ich die wollen dadurch die tür
durch glaubte einfach rein kann ich
nicht die schlangen immer wieder zurück
wenn wir wieder hier ist es schalter ich
hab den schalter gedrückt als müssen wir
wahrscheinlich wieder zurück hat sich
die andere da unten öffnet die
handschuhe kann ich gebrauchen vor
sozialfonds
einfach ausgegeben
wir leben wieder generiert okay es ist
die tür laufen hallo herr alter krass
aber irgendwie mag ich den hut einfach
nur so abschlachten bisschen als
zuschauer können wenn man die kommentare
schreibt ob euch das gefällt oder eher
nicht so rosig kognition 6 die
playstation ist optional helbig
overdrive network und major station
network ich hab doch die hessen wo ist
ja sind so computer schon gesagt
siehst du mal dass ein pc ist das so
eine kurz aufgebot
naja so sperma oder so ein heer letzt
sind die powerplaytore wien at work with
your help and power plant ok wat ich
muss auf einen sonderschalter drücken
etwas milch oder ist okay so es geht los
ein schild formen not fixes wikileaks
work skidata okay das interface denn die
negativ ground standing charge intense
ecken negativ ground okay das positiv
hier ist negativ karten hier ist negativ
ja ich weiß du lassen der befehl zombies
gerade weil wir halten alle nur eins aus
glaube ich ja stimmt alter noch so viele
wenn aber so ein 1 boss wer einfach der
zu der wie viel leben hat keine ahnung
wer zum ersten mal okay wir müssen uns
gleich ob diese negative dings stellen
charge in 321 negativer als letzter
läufer
genau hierauf müssen verstehen beim ok
verteidigt mann ganz groß muskulös das
essen aber ich hab mich solche tollen
trinken wie du da die kann man sich kaum
ok ok ok kommt dann stelle ich mir drauf
jetzt einfach hier stehen bleiben und
panschen